ان نفتح حلقتنا بهذا الخبر والانجاز
التاريخي في ليله لن ينساها محبو الردس
قالوا انه اسوا مواسمه مع ليفربول وان
ارقامه لم تعد كالسابق لكن الواقع يحكي
قصه اخرى صلاح يصبح الهداف التاريخي
لليفربول في مباريات الدوري الانجليزي
بعدما وصل لهدفه رقم 129 في البطوله وخلال
وخمس مباراه خاضها بقميص الريتس منذ
انضمامه في 2017 احرز صلاح هدفين وصنع
مثلهما في اكتساح لفريق غريمه مانشستر
يونايتد بنتيجه سبعه مقابل لا شيء ضمن
مباريات في الجوله السادسه والعشرين من
بطوله الدوري وبالانجاز غير المسبوق تفوق
صلاح على اسطوره الفريق المعتذر روبي
باولر يتصدر قائمه هدف في الفريق في
الدوري جنبا الى جنب مع قائمه هدفي الفريق
في دوري ابطال اوروبا الذي يتربى على
عرشها في فبراير الماضي